she was just dehydrated and she got some
fluids Charlie demilio gives an update
on her sister Dixie following her
hospitalization she's gonna be at the
demilio Footwear launch tonight so you
will see her she is coming she's just
getting ready right now yeah she's
feeling better
ET spoke with the tick tock star just
hours after Dixie's Health scare which
happened on the same day as their
dimelio Footwear launch party I mean
tonight is about celebrating everything
that the entire demilio Footwear team
did to make these shoes come to life and
it's a very exciting night for us our
first demilio Brands brand and I think
that it's just so exciting for everyone
and I'm very happy to see everyone in
the shoes I mean I'm in heels a lot with
carpets and interviews and everything
and I'm very used to you know having to
take my shoes off between everything
that I do because my feet are hurting
and I think there's just so much that
I've learned from you know wearing heels
for so long that there was things that I
wanted to
help and get this E.T got to exclusively
kick it inside the bash I'm seeing neon
signs which are absolutely adorable hey
guys
walk in this is so cute you have the
Footwear candles those are the shoes
that I'm wearing right now they also
come in a pink very exciting it's warm
right here which is nice but I guess
it's time to go into the big room
we have
Brian's Booth Booth by Bryant demilio
Footwear Style
Bryant has been doing this booth for
quite a while and he's had literally
everybody in it but I have yet to take a
photo in the booth so tonight is my
night very exciting do you want to say
hi Bryant
what's up guys it's Brian here
um I'm excited to have the booth here
yeah it looks in insane I'm excited to
finally use it did you do some test
shots
wow with the demilio Footwear pretty
sick if I do say so myself
shall we continue exploring
oh my gosh is this the first time ever
in the booth how long have you been
doing the booth I've been doing it for
like 10 months now
10 months and I still haven't done it
first time right here this is crazy I'm
excited
wow I've never seen this before so this
is pretty crazy we have a lot of things
that say demilio Footwear on it cute
mirrors cute flowers got the video from
shoot day up there a swing it's a little
too high I have a slight fear of heights
but
who knows where the night will take us
what is this is this real
oh my goodness it's real ice
and that's an actual shoe Bar menu based
off of the shoes this is the Ravina I'm
wearing those right now very exciting
there's some places to sit over here for
everyone
demilio Footwear is everywhere cute
little step stool I heard that there
will be models modeling the shoes on the
stools but
I don't know if that's private
information as right now I love the
colors of the flowers very cute we got
lots of pink shoes so it's very exciting
more videos of you know the meetings
about what the shoes are going to be
took a lot of meetings to finally pick
but you can see all of the final shoes
up there lots of very adorable
chandeliers
I'm excited to see this party this is
insane
wow I'm so happy thanks ET so much for
coming on this little demilio Footwear
Party tour with me the shoes are out
right now and I'm so excited to see you
guys all in them bye
[Music]